[Music]
all right so some feel good news guys
yes feel good positivity I'll find a way
to make it negative let's go Good
Samaritan story yeah I suppose a [ __ ]
scoundrel you know I already hate him
already he's Mexican you already started
it off bad give me Filipino you're right
okay how about Old Mexico though he's
already [ __ ] up okay so he's 19 years
old universe he was driving to his local
Wells Fargo Bank branch he's bawling and
so he needed some money for so through
the whole thing here is that he needed
to deposit some money into his bank
account to make an online purchase that
was for his dad I believe oh his
grandfather to buy socks for his cramp
oh okay
so please grandpa leather socks well why
does he do all my binky why did you give
him his socks oh maybe he had cash maybe
I should put it in the missionary so
then he drove up to the ATM and when he
pulled his truck up he saw a clear
plastic bag on the ground and he says it
was a footlong stack of 50 and 20 dollar
bills won't come true this guy's so
[ __ ] dumb you don't know what he did
I know he made it to the news he's dumb
I've been gone been applied and got out
higher and had retired there so I
totaled 135 thousand dollars I was
plastic bag yes why would someone be so
irresponsible it happens yeah so drug
deal they weren't in basketball shorts
just fell out well it turned out that it
was the company that services the
machines that are supposed to restock
the
I know the employee taught me did that
purpose like to leave it out and then
one of their friends come they're gonna
[ __ ] face charges you know Serena
oh you know Serena I know Serena that's
why it was left there and so Jose says
that not once for a second did he ever
think about keeping it
me neither there's cameras there you
already turn it in he had probably he's
probably at for half enough you watch
the video just staring at it like what
to do and we talked to a new yeah he was
like you picked it up in Slovak gasps oh
there was a hundred grand in front of a
bank I would have brought it back in the
bank it does set up dude for sure it's
250 thousand dollars no yeah cuz he felt
like they were might there might be like
someone that run up to him or like maybe
it's like a social experiment or
whatever you do know right yeah this
will thinks too much I want to grab it
put it in the car it's landing - I'm
driving fast he's getting out of the car
and then I jump it I pull up jump in my
mom's car drive off some real change
thing is if you went to the ATM already
they know that they'll just check the
time stamp of who deposited what I mean
all that stuff so maybe you didn't get a
chance if you didn't go then good for
you bar that's the way to do it by the
time already I'm in Panama the facts are
we coming with you no I'm God I don't
even know if at that point is it
stealing at that point is it stealing
what is it yes of course job you know
what you do it's a sign of God it's a
whole thing
they're testing you if you're right if I
hey guys I just found this money I'm a
go give it to homeless people right and
then you leave someone catch you like oh
that's [ __ ] up would you do it like oh
no look I was gonna give it to homeless
people
a couple give them a couple well you
don't even do that you just say like I
was about to distribute it okay what I
was gonna do it like next week and the
next week comes I do like next well I
like the one I was sold a new boat so
destroy that when I got sent the meth or
the rice actually cuz then we got many
packages right you got metacenter
suspect Wow $150,000 worth of fentanyl
we turn into the cops she doesn't like
men if it was heroin daughter than a
different story you lose money you would
it turn into the cops
yes but it's not cash all right but how
many friends will I know that I couldn't
turn that in and they could have flipped
it for me yeah we're gonna sell them to
your friends I'm like urine yeah no no
no they don't do it but they would have
gave it to someone that would've been
like all this attire
all right cuz I got thrown like 20 not
in this room though but uh yeah if I
knew I could not do that you're such a
good person I was but then now knowing
ya know what I think it is it's because
it was drugs if it was just cash it
would have been out of it more afraid of
the time yeah you know this tells me you
know that that one show what would you
do yeah like if you guys were all on
that show everybody would fail that
experiment I wouldn't fail I'm a good
person I told you Nelson I'm bringing it
back you're going with Bart to that Bank
Tom you know I would talk him out of it
1,000% possible I would have taped her
mouth shut and do the trunk you see but
I'm still the good person in the
scenario I would throw the money in my
car and I'll walk into the bank and I
said it's hypothetically speaking if
there was a bag of money in the parking
lot right can you replay the tape and
see if I picked it up
let's wat like can we check that out and
can you rewind it even more and see who
it belonged to
because if you can I'll personally give
that money to them but I won't leave it
at the bank you know why I don't trust
the [ __ ] cuz they might be like hey
there's a bag of money
want to split it maybe like we only
found $100 on the floor exactly that's
how I always think about when there's a
bag of money that goes to the police
station say hey I found this in the park
and I think it's drug money and the
police are like thank you son you did
the right thing and then they give you a
certificate and they give you the keys
and they only found guess what $20.00
what happened to them yeah yeah it's
like it's all depending on how much you
find because if you go to the if you go
inside the bank keep it you know I mean
with Jose really found three hundred
thousand that's one thing but he said
only a hundred and fifty thousand there
was a lot of room in that bag like when
you buy a bag of chips hey would you
would you exchange a hundred thousand
for that certificate I thought no I
would picture is gonna make him a
million dollars now he's gonna be made
fun of for the rest of his life like
people like us we're gonna laugh like
Adam you guys aren't thinking long term
I'll tell you my scheme after this like
a motivational speaker Alberto Jose all
right so back to Jose story so then when
he saw that wad of cash he ended up
calling the police and like you saw he
turned it in and that's when they found
out that it was us the company that
services the ATM that left it behind and
so city officials honored him in a
ceremony outside Albuquerque's Police
Academy and then the police chief
presented him with that plaque that I
showed you why didn't he get a [ __ ]
statue then I'd be like it should have
been a gold statue of him with holding a
bag of [ __ ] money like this yeah
actually he should be on the phone with
the police full with the police in the
back
that's like this yeah with this car door
opened it mixed them but the tattletale
right he is a student who intends to
study criminal justice so the police
chief invited him to apply for a job as
a public service aide at the police
department also the Albuquerque ESPN
Radio presented like this radio station
presented him with some sign sports
memorabilia at the station had included
and a football autograph from former NFL
and University of New Mexico linebacker
Brian Urlacher
exactly rookie though maybe the Danish
it that goes down the radio station also
threw in six season tickets for UNM
football and know if it's still a
hundred grand and then at least three
local businesses presented him with five
hundred dollars each with one of them a
restaurants adding a $100 gift card like
a thousand I feel like turning this in
it's not that big of a deal
no nobody else is like oh that's a lot
of money but it's like this torn money
outside of a bank
his dad is so upset [ __ ] super dad
he's like god damn that could have been
a new truck and [ __ ] this week obey
talks about he kept hearing his parents
like me huh Little Joe everybody wrong
mom told him he did the right thing is
she was so proud of it when she called
him and then started squeezing a stress
ball yeah you did the right thing sure
beat his ass
no so he said that he had his mom's
voice and her chocolate in the back of
her his head yes way out watching me so
my prayers can't be my ass what a
chocolate is sandals flip-flops bathing
and it's it's a threat yeah exactly
what I was telling you is anything $100
or less you returned that not a hundred
[Applause]
he says quote my parents always taught
me to work for my own stolen money will
never last you you genius about finding
money he's genius you know why he's
playing the long game as soon as I heard
criminal justice he's going for the
[ __ ] chief of police of Albuquerque
use that his campaign yeah yes remember
when I was 19 I won the album cope
Albuquerque football tickets because I
returned $100,000 I'm honorable and I've
been honorable for the last 40 years for
the City of Albuquerque vote me Bob he's
playing the long game corrupt it from
the inside he's a nice kid
oh no wait what's the long word okay so
he returned a hundred thousand right but
if he thought you know but if I was him
that's what I'm saying cuz I told you my
scheme right this is my scheme not your
scheme all right when I become the Chief
of Police you know how much their salary
is dude hundreds of thousands of dollars
a year but you gotta work dude this one
either heat that was in his hand if I
got that would be like [ __ ] being a
police officer
exactly it's gonna run out yeah
Mac you're smart that's less than crypto
but his dream is to be a criminal
justice man still do it you can't do it
if you're tainted my friend what are you
talking about you can't do it most of
them are everyone is
in your world but not in mine touch what
have you hit man a good one
haven't you seen Dexter
[Music]
[Music]